you famously worked in publishing oh yes
I did yes a little while
what did you do we in publishing I have
no idea this was in preparation for
Bridget Jones yeah how long how long did
you do it for ah let's see I went over
in January we started filming after
Easter so yeah good few months yeah so
you must have done something well yeah I
did I got the coffee I made the coffee I
had to you know cut anything out of you
know the local periodicals or that are
about the authors that the publishing
company represented so I do that and
then follow them away and I had to
organize the the book launches and
things like that yeah well and who do
they say you were they said that I was
Bridget Cavendish so a relative of the
gentleman who was the owner of the
publishers which explained why I got the
job with absolutely no skills whatsoever
I meant to ask you earlier about working
with Martin Scorsese what have you
analyzed why you two guys gel so well
why you produce this extraordinary work
I'm just very lucky that that Marty is
the kind of person who genuinely if you
give an idea he'll say yeah let's try
that let's try it okay that worse that
won't work or he'll cut it out and he's
just that way with me and he's this way
with other people too so I I'm just
lucky that we've done these these
projects together over the years and we
have a special relationship
yeah and are the stories about Mart
Scorsese using his mother true that he
would have her on set cooking real
Italian food yeah mom she Katie where
she would do that as I remember and and
she made great pizza I remember when I
opened the Tribeca grill I was seriously
considering if she would even want to do
it of getting her recipe for the pizza
that she made it was so simple it was
just great
I've even got a picture of her on set
she's actually in the movie so
this is his mom yeah and then she really
cooked the food yeah those where they
had the real kind of gangsters on set
well there were people around who you
know the same with casino and stuff
that's that's part of it does that help
or does it make you a bit nervous
no no everybody you know people like to
be in movies and part of them and the
guys in that world as much if not more
than most people yeah and you talk about
that world what is it about movies in
that world cuz almost since they started
making movies they've been telling
stories about gangsters of the Mafia and
mobsters and now here we are in 2019 and
this is still a big deal what is the
appeal of those characters I don't know
I guess it's cuz they defy the law in
some way and they still they have their
own laws their own there's there's more
of an honor like especially the
Godfather I think especially at that
time in the late 60s the Godfather would
the government and everything of yet nah
more I think that the the idea that this
culture had more there was more respect
and more more structure and more right
and wrong then we were seeing in in the
war and with our leaders and not being
told the truth about what was really
going on and I think so that that's why
it was a part of its appeal yeah today
we have a kind of a weird twisted
president who thinks he's a gangster
who's not not even a good gangster
because this is a guy that you know even
gangsters like honor among thieves you
shake a hand you have your word that's
all you have yeah there's your word and
they have your word and that's it this
guy is not the king
I didn't even bring him up the latest
one and so what's that like is it
emotional or is it just kind of a no it
was terrible it was terrible the veteran
I'd started recording woody in 1991
that's when we actually got together do
the first one yes he wasn't born then
I'm gonna say happy concede really
having sex I think
[Laughter]
to the picture now it's a long time well
and you record these things over about
four years you go in about every eight
months and deliver up under everything
that the writers have come up with and
and the last session was I thought it
was just odds and ends you don't have to
do a little bit of this real and a
little bit of that maybe one whole
sequence but I was in the same studio in
the same microphone with the same glass
- b.o.b at Disney and when they they
they said okay great thanks and just
like that xx however many years were
over and I had to say wait guys guys
guys
there's gotta be there's gotta be
something else you know we got pretty
much got at all no no no no no there's
gotta be I gotta say come on guys or I
gotta say something like let's get back
to Bonnie's room or look out buzz
there's got to be some line they said no
you're done and my really uncomfortable
and all you can do is say well oh my oh
my my oh my and the only thing to do was
to go and get my car and drive away and
I was you know I heard the music and the
Sun was going down in my mind I was like
[Music]
first Ronan you also you want a really
good prize
what did you win I won a trip to Florida
when I was a kid how you want it I will
I want it when I was when I was a kid
and I had never entered into a
competition like that before and it was
the first day of the summer holidays
when I was I was like 9 or 10 or
something and Jeri Ryan who you know was
this very well-known Irish DJ at home
he's passed away now but he was it was
really incredible and his show was like
the top shell in the country and Shrek 2
had just come out that's how long ago
was and he was given away this holiday
to Florida and what you had to do was
you to phone in as one of the characters
and Shrek 2 and tell Jerry why you
deserved the holiday and I haven't
started properly actin yet at that stage
or anything but dad was an actor so I
was around sort of like you know
improvisers and things like that and I
was like you should go in first just why
not we had never been on like a proper
holiday oh god okay so we got a little
notepad like tiny little notepad and we
wrote down like a tiny little script of
what I was gonna say just this short
little script and they got on and I
think I was one of the first kids on and
I and I did it as the gingerbread man
and and so then five days later he he
found up and told me that weird well you
were on The Late Late back in Ireland
they found this clip so this is this is
two little clips put together this it's
your gingerbread man yeah followed by
which I really liked your reaction to
winning so he's very squeaky voice now
Saoirse is ten years of age now which
character of you chosen
[Music]
oh my I need a holiday well I've got
news for you you're going to Florida
[Applause]
Meryl Streep yeah I mean you're sure
like you have scenes with Meryl Streep a
shared space with no we shed a carriage
for a whole day and the room for a whole
day it was this better girl does she
give you a little pep talk beforehand so
now you're going to be in a carriage of
no sleep you know does anyone prepare
you for it no you kind of just know that
she's she's in the room or she's
somewhere in the house because
everybody's on best behavior
and everybody lights really quickly and
everybody sets up cameras very quickly
because Merrill's around so you always
can tell that she's somewhere didn't you
say that that when you were doing
outside scene but she has this power she
speaks and things happen
she's we were in a carriage for a long
time and it takes a while to reset shots
because we were in horses we walk behind
horses and it took about 20 minutes each
time and it was cold and we were in
Boston and Timmy came up and kind of
jumped up on the carriage and just as he
jumped up on the carriage a waft of chip
smell came in and she suddenly then
wanted chips and within about I'd say
ten minutes there was a gasping PA
like
in a carriage dripping in my fine
clothes I did Who am I gonna sulfide I
thought you just do a I told you to a
kind of like a make it do things
[Applause]
okay then I think one two three four
seven positions okay okay so first of
all you put this little show here and
hang on like this and realize okay this
is the first position I know I killed
you want come on here we go yeah first
position duska first and then take on at
first and second third and fourth hay
fever I've got my own leg but six and
then we're fancy one in cases somebody
attack you in the back like this oh good
I thought so yes Francie
[Music]
[Applause]
direct you've got John Travolta and
you're showing how to dance your
teaching about your dance I didn't have
to teach John Travolta how to dance
could you does that know oh yeah no III
wanted him to dance a particular way it
was a certain kind of clout
[Music]
[Applause]
because it's a twist now twist can be
kind of boring so part of the thing
about it is I wanted Vincent and Mia ie
Ormond Thurmond to have two different
characters when they when they twist all
right when Vince twists I wanted him to
be kind of rich but when me a twist the
image that I had in my mind was the zsa
zsa gabor cat from the Aristocats and
there's that one little scene with the
Aristocats dance as she coming
[Laughter]
[Applause]
don't try this at home
really go I'll sit on this side of you
okay perfect okay here we go okay in
your own time okay here we go here we
haven't done one for a while I'm sorry
I'm probably more nervous than you are
really sorry that's not comforting I'm
not gonna say that wasn't very
professional I'm so scared my hands are
shaking but you don't
[Applause]
does it hurt a little funny don't we
make your finest work
you do seem happy in your work good I
like doing it neaten it up like one
we're off like backstage
[Applause]
[Music]
you